لنبدا هنا بدايه من جنين تحديدا من حاجز
الجلمه شمالي المدينه مقاومون فلسطينيون
اطلقوا النار على قوه عسكريه عند الحاجز
وتمكنوا من الفرار قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ردت ايضا باطلاق النار لم تصل
ولم تعتقل احد وقامت بعمليه تمشيط واسعه
في المنطقه والاحياء القريبه اما العمليه
الاوسع التي تجري في هذه الاثناء نشوان هي
تحديدا في مدينه نابلس قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بقوات كبيره اقتحمت المدينه من
حاجزي بيت فريك ودير شرف الهدف واضح حتى
هذه اللحظه انه يستهدف
مطبعه تعود
لاستاذ جامعي هو اي معتقل منذ شهرين قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قامت حتى لي ليس بفتح
بوابه المطبعه بطريقه عاديه او طلبت من
العائله فتحه بل قام جيب عسكري بتخريب
البوابه الرئيسيه تحطيم كامل
لمحتويات ومصادره حتى ما تم تحطيمه لا احد
يعرف السبب ذلك في المنطقه المحيطه بمخيم
بلاطه وايضا في ذات الوقت هناك حتى هذه
اللحظه فيما يعرف بحي المعاجين استدعاء
للعائله من الزوجه والابناء التحقيق معهم
ميدانيا لا احد يعرف ما الذي يحدث من هذه
التحقيقات او الهدف منها رغم ان هذا
الاستاذ الجامعي معتقل في سجون الاحتلال
الا الاسرائيلي عمليه عسكريه واسعه ولا
زالت مستمره ايضا كانت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قد نفذت عمليه عسكريه خاطفه في
مدينه قلقيليه اقصى شمال الضفه الغربيه في
البدايه دخلت قوه راجله تعرضت لالقاء عبوه
محليه الصنع من قبل مقاومين فلسطينيين
القوها على هذه القوه فقامت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بادخال تعزيزات من اليات
عسكريه قاموا بمصادره عدد من
كاميرات المراقبه المثبته على بعض المحال
التجاريه والمنازل كما اعتلى عدد من
القناصه اسطح عدد من ال نايات وخلال
مواجهات بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اصيب شاب فلسطيني
ايضا اقتحام وعلى عجاله كان في ضاحيه
شويكه في مدينه طول كرم وا ايضا حتى هذه
اللحظه واضح اننا لسنا امام عمليه اعتقال
او اصابات ايضا قبل ذلك كان هناك عمليه
عسكريه امتدت لاكثر من اربع ساعات في بلده
يعبد جنوب غرب جنين قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت
البلده انتشرت في عدد من الاحياء
واقامت عدد قام عدد من الشبان بالقاء
عبوات ناسفه اندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه ومن ثم
قامت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالانسحاب
بالكامل